WASH MY HANDS.
- OKAY, SWEETIE.
- OKAY.
- SEE YOU IN A SECOND.
- [laughing]
BUDDY!
- UM, I'M SORRY, UH,
THAT SEAT IS ACTUALLY TAKEN.
MY GIRLFRIEND
IS IN THE BATHROOM,
AND SHE SHOULD BE BACK
ANY SECOND,
SO YOU CANNOT
SIT THERE.
- YOU DON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE ME,
DO YOU?
- NO. NO, I D--I DON'T--
I DON'T KNOW YOU.
- WE WERE IN
THAT HUMAN CENTIPEDE TOGETHER!
- I SAID,
I DO NOT KNOW YOU.
- THREE YEARS AGO,
WE WERE KIDNAPPED
BY THE CRAZY GERMAN SCIENTIST
WHO SURGICALLY CONNECTED US
INTO A SINGLE HUMAN
DIGESTIVE CHAIN.
THERE WERE THREE OF US,
I WAS IN THE MIDDLE,
YOU WERE AT THE END,
THE OTHER GUY WAS UP FRONT.
YOUR MOUTH
WAS SEWN TO MY BUTTHOLE!
- OKAY, YES,
I REMEMBER!
AND AFTER YEARS OF THERAPY,
I FINALLY PUT THAT BEHIND ME.
- PROBABLY SHOULD'VE SAID
YOU PUT IT BEHIND ME,
IF YOU CATCH MY DRIFT.
[laughing] I'M SORRY.
SORRY!
YOU ALREADY CAUGHT MY DRIFT.
I'M SORRY! [laughs]
THAT'S IT.
IT WAS RIGHT THERE
IN FRONT OF ME.
- REALLY? REALLY?
- [laughing] I'M SORRY.
I GUESS IT WAS RIGHT THERE
IN FRONT OF YOU.
THAT'S IT.
[laughing]
I'M SORRY.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
[laughing] HOW ARE YOU?
- IS THERE SOMETHING ELSE
I CAN HELP YOU WITH?
- UM--OH!
- HEY, [bleep] EATER.
- NO [bleep] WAY!
- HEY! [laughs]
FRONT MAN! [laughs]
- THIS IS A [bleep] NIGHTMARE.
- HEY, BACK MAN.
BACK MAN!
- NO,
DON'T CALL ME THAT.
- AH!
- HEY, COP A SQUAT.
- NO!
- OOH, CHILI.
OLD HABITS DIE HARD?
[laughs]
- NICE ONE! [laughs]
- NOW I CAN'T EAT IT.
- OH, WORD?
- WHY ARE YOU
HAPPY TO SEE HIM?
- COME ON, MAN!
YOU KNOW, WE ALL SHARED
THE SAME EXPERIENCE.
- NO, WE DIDN'T.
HE WAS IN THE FRONT.
NOBODY
[bleep] IN HIS MOUTH!
- THAT IS TRUE.
- DO YOU EVER STOP EATING?
EVER?
- ONLY WHEN I'M [bleep].
[laughs]
- OKAY.
- BUT ME AND YOU,
RIGHT?
- ME AND YOU WHAT?
- I MEAN,
WE WERE
IN THE SAME BOAT.
- NOPE, YOU TWO
WERE IN THE SAME BOAT.
YOU BOTH [bleep]
IN SOMEONE'S MOUTH.
I DIDN'T GET TO [bleep]
IN ANYONE'S MOUTH!
- "GET TO"?
- WHEN DO I GET TO [bleep]
IN ANYBODY'S MOUTH, HUH?
WHEN DO I GET TO [bleep]
IN SOMEBODY'S MOUTH?
- STEVEN!
- HON--I--NO.
THESE GUYS--I CAN EXPLAIN THIS.
I CAN EXPLAIN THIS.
YOU--
OH, YOU'RE DISGUSTED?
YOU--OH, NOW,
YOU'RE GONNA LEAVE?
[scoffs] OH, YEAH.
THAT'S GREAT. OH, YEAH.
ONCE AGAIN,
I'M THE ASSHOLE.